first i would love to get to some
headlines so let's hit the desk
[Applause]
everybody it is time for drew's news the
good news feast so big you might need to
unbutton your newspam and we have got
the most epic desk guest today he's the
captain of his own news ship every night
on cnn the award-winning journalist with
the best giggle on tv
[Applause]
i was just watching you the other night
i'm just titillated by your conversation
with william shatner i was beyond elated
90 years old and he's like incredible
he's so quick and sharp and funny and
sarcastic and
and he's up in space oh well i mean
listen i would be remiss not to also
introduce my trustiest news co-pilot in
the business it's rozzy rossman
i've been a long time fan of ross
matthews i think i reached out to you
like a long time ago just to praise you
well i'll never forget it anderson
cooper thanks for bringing it up i
i actually met you for the first time at
the 2004 republican convention i was
covering it for the tonight show and i
was like i have to be anderson cooper so
i just look for a little white head i
just look for you
yeah i do stand out you do and then i
saw you i tapped you on your shoulder
and you turned around and you said ross
ross and i was like i need a diaper
i just couldn't believe anderson cooper
knew who i was i would now be able to
change that diaper
[Applause]
18 months old
and we just had halloween did why did i
dress up so yeah he did i actually
brought up a picture he a friend of mine
chip kid gave me i know it's a weird
picture let me just quickly explain chip
kid who's uh did the book jacket for my
for my book he's an amazing designer he
has an incredible batman collection and
his mom in the 60s made him that batman
cape that one that one and gay and so
chip gave me the cape that he had as a
kid and one of those vintage batman
masks from when i was a kid and my son
is obsessed with cleaning products i was
going to say i see a vacuum
it doesn't actually vacuum it just makes
the sound of a vacuum and it is the
greatest gift he has ever received in
his life can i just throw this out there
they should make it vacuum because while
you're doing it might as well clean up a
little i learned to take care of myself
at a very early age
right you did yeah it set me up well
um well speaking of staying up late
hours parenting how are you sleeping by
the way i this is embarrassing uh from
the beginning my son has slept like
12-13 hours a night like straight
through good karma i know that's good
karma
well um
i watch you every night talk about the
most real stuff on the planet so
um here we go
right here oh it's about to get so real
because the material girl aha madonna
she still likes to burn that midnight
oil rolling stone reports that madonna
loves to stay up late her bedtime these
days is 4 00 a.m wow and she is using
some of that time to work on the script
for her upcoming biopic
um first of all
literally this this this makes me cagey
even talking about a four a.m bedtime
four a.m seems late yeah that does not
seem i mean i yeah well
at that point what's the point in going
to bed i think you just sort of just go
through the next day so you love madonna
right i am a big madonna fan yes yes and
i'm looking forward to whatever her
biopic turns out to be and stuff but i
think she should get some more sleep i
think i'm worried about that
oh look at you guys together look
there's looking that's you and that's
madonna right there
what does madonna say to you yeah what
is she saying to you right now
i don't i don't know you don't remember
i don't ride she was saying very
important things at the time i i don't
recall my most embarrassing madonna
moment was i went to see her at the
barclays center and she they pulled me
up on stage to dance and i do not dance
in public it was the most embarrassing
moment of my
there's like 15 000 of the videos online
because there's a barclays center it's
quite large yeah a lot of people have
cameras
yeah uh turn breaking news we're not as
cool as madonna okay get some rest girl
all right next up dating app tinder's
doing something a little interesting
refinery 29 reports they've launched the
plus one hub where you can find a date
for your next wedding if you're single
go to plus one yeah a survey found sixty
percent of people are more likely to go
to a wedding if they have a plus one
what i this i don't understand at all
first of all when i heard this i thought
it meant a plus one like it was like
couples looking for a plus one for uh
do you know what that's called if you're
a couple looking for a third a throttle
maybe we're a threat
tune in next week
we're in news
yeah that's true would you ever do a
plus one uh
to a wedding yeah well i don't
understand first of all why would any
plus one who doesn't know the wedding
why would they want to go to somebody's
stranger's wedding some other stranger
who they just met online i would totally
go to a wedding with a stranger why
would anyone want me to go to a wedding
with them i would go in a heartbeat
but we know you
so you're like a guarantor i know
because you're fun and you would be
fantastic as a date but like i agree and
you put out but
i have no idea but i mean i've just
heard i'm just saying what i've heard
stop it i'm an engaged man don't talk
about like i can't do it
oh my god i just got invited to ross's
wedding i know i'm so excited you want
to come
understood and understood
you can you can just you can just send a
gift
[Laughter]
all right here's the next story uh this
comes from martha stewart living a new
study by the american psychological
association finds that people actually
enjoy deeper conversations with
strangers more than simple small talk
but psychologists say that we lean into
chit chat because we underestimate how
much others are actually interested in
us and we overestimate how awkward it
would be
i'm not sure i believe that but do you
like deep talk with strangers yeah i'd
like to say hello to ellen who i met at
macy's this weekend
that's not a joke hi ellen we had this
deep conversation that she's worked
there for 39 years and her ex-husband
and this and that and i found myself
having a deep conversation with a
stranger and when my fiance walked up he
goes it's been 20 minutes and the point
was is that i just found her fascinating
now i haven't talked that long to any of
my friends in years but there was just
something about a stranger and i could
confide in her i i kind of get it my dad
was that way and my mom told me the
story that one time she
this was in the 70s she called him up on
the phone at his office to try to get in
touch with him and the the line was busy
for for hours finally she got through
she's like who are you talking to and he
goes oh it was a wrong number and it was
just some random wrong number that he
had engaged in conversation and they
ended up having a three-hour
conversation yeah
yeah
yeah that's not me i i would not no
i'm a reclusive so i'm painfully awkward
and shy so any conversation with me is
relatively awkward and yet
you are so curious yes well yeah but
that's that's a work and that's you know
i'm interested in things i'm interested
in talking to people uh and it's easier
for me to ask questions to people and i
like engaging with people and learning
about them but personal interaction on a
daily basis it like takes a lot out of
me like after this i will need to
decompress for a little while nothing
personal but just me it's just me do you
hear that jew we broke him yes
he's gonna need a nap and a bottle
you're gonna have to get in bed thank
god my drupal will take care of you
i
once read this passage in a book and it
changed my life forever i was 14 years
old it's called desiderata um and it
just had this passage that said listen
to people for they have their story too
that was it that was all i needed to
read to become a curious open-minded
better listener my mom i had a saying
which was from a scottish philosopher
named mclaren who said uh be kind
because everybody you meet is fighting a
great battle and i think that's so
important and let's just be kind to each
other a little bit
that's it
[Music]